monsieur compte un taux merci d'être en
direct avec nous assure rt france alors
le calme est finalement revenu mais des
tensions tout à l'heure entre gendarmes
et manifestants il y a même mur du gaz
lacrymogène comment on explique que la
manifestation ne s'est pas déroulée dans
le calme
du début à la fin alors il faut remettre
les choses en perspective tout de même
et elle nous a mis deux citations s'est
bien passé dans une manière générale
simplement que malheureusement ça
devient une sorte de marronniers au
début de la manifestation place de la
république
vous avez des éléments perturbateurs qui
ont voulu ne pas se diriger sur l'
itinéraire prédéfini et ont jeté des
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre
donc c'était quantité minime par rapport
au nombre des manifestants qui étaient
vraiment heureusement pacifique
donc voilà j'ai eu usage à un peu de
coercition mais les choses se passent
bien et d'une manière assez bon enfant
et j'ai augure que cette manifestation
se terminait d'une belle manière
donc pour vous le dispositif policier
qui avait été prévu était bien été
efficace bien sûr tout à fait voilà
comme je disais la disputation c'est pas
parce qu'il ya quelques perturbateurs
que la manifestation se passe pas
c'était uniquement le fait de quelques
individus qui je vous le rappelle ans
chez les projectiles sur mes collègues
et des collections défendu en les
éloignant à coups de gaz lacrymogènes
alors tout à l'heure on a eu l'interview
du président emmanuel macron qui s'est
prêté aux autres additionnel entretien
du 14 juillet et on lui a posé des
questions sur les contrôles d'identité
et notamment sur les délits de faciès 1
qui ont été a dénoncé notamment par le
défenseur des droits
emmanuel macron a promis de
généralisation des caméras
sait-on qu'est ce que vous en pensez eh
bien écoutez c'est très bien parce que
nous c'est ce que nous demandons depuis
des années vous avez des services
spécialisés qui sont déjà équipés de
caméras piétons mais nous demandons nous
même la généralisation de ces caméras
piétons ça permettra de protéger nos
collègues puisque d'interpellations ou
les contrôles seront filmés et là vous
verrez tout le monde vers à l'évidence
que les collègues lorsqu'ils contrôlent
c'est dur dans un cadre bien défini un
cadre légal et aussi c'est qu'on
contrôle pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
comportements et des habitudes et des
attitudes par bonds qui sont suspectes
donc les policiers nationaux de ce pays
sont vraiment pour la généralisation des
caméras piétons ça nous fait pas peur
bien au contraire c'est un outil qui
nous protègera si je peux me permettre
monsieur contento la généralisation des
caméras piéton s'est pas uniquement pour
vous protéger vous les policiers
d'effectuer les contrôles mais justement
pour protéger la population qui estime
parfois être victimes de délits de
faciès
il est tout à fait d'écouter nous
verrons lorsque déjà il faudra investir
plusieurs millions d'euros parce que les
caméras piétons que nous avons en ce
moment en dotation ont une très faible
autonomie au bout d'une heure ou deux il
ya plus de batterie et deviennent
vraiment elle ne fonctionne plus donc il
faut déjà investir que le ministère de
l'intérieur investi dans du matériel
neuf et performant et lorsque ces
généralisations seront faites de caméras
piétons eh bien nous verrons et on fera
un bilan est beaucoup de gens seront
étonnés
alors on parle beaucoup de convergences
des luttes on l'a vu dans cette
manifestation de soignants il y avait
également des idées jaune et vous aussi
les policiers avaient des revendications
oui tout à fait on a des revendications
d'ailleurs nous avons nous avons nous
avons rencontré le premier ministre et
le promu et le ministre de l'intérieur
pardon monsieur darmana moi même je vais
rencontrer au commissariat du 19ème
arrondissement c'était mercredi dans la
nuit et on lui expliquer que c'est pas
parce qu'on a changé de glisse de
l'intérieur que la colère des policiers
s'est apaisée bien au contraire et qu'il
fallait aller vite qu'ils avaient des
grands dossiers sur la table d'andré
généraux qui n'ont toujours pas abouti
alors il nous a promis d'aller vite
écoutez dont acte on lui souhaite bonne
chance mais on lui a répété qu' il n'y
aura malheureusement pas d'état de grâce
pour monsieur d'armement
alors que la vis à vis des policiers
quelles sont ces grands dossiers dont
vous venez de parler écouter déjà dans
un premier temps on voudrait quand même
une loi d'orientation de programmation
de sécurité intérieure
donc pour rénover aussi du matériel au
niveau de la police nationale
pour exemple nous avons à peu près dix
mille véhicules qui sont en voie de
réforme
la courbe des achats la structure elle
de matériel depuis deux ans décline au
début la police nationale nous avons
aussi des revendications on voudrait
bien soutenu et protégé à savoir que
lorsque l'institution et diffamer je
fais exemple par exemple à camélia
jordana qui avait
10 sur un plateau de télévision que la
police passe à créer dès que
systématiquement le nuit sur donateurs
ailleurs dépose plainte contre les
personnes qui diffament l'institution ça
n'avait pas été fait c'est notre
syndicat l'époque qui avait déposé
plainte contre elle donc voilà on
voudrait des dépôts de pain systématique
vous avez vu je vais pas faire un
catalogue de toutes leurs revendications
parce que demain matin on y serait
encore mais aussi la liquidation des
heures supplémentaires qui avaient été
promises
nous avons des millions des millions
d'heures supplémentaires à excuser or
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on est plus que les
stocks de l'année nous avons un stock
historique vous avez des personnes
les policiers qui ont dix ans des heures
supplémentaires et qui voudraient bien
ce qu'ils refusent de se les faire payer
avant d'aller à la retraite
donc voilà pour ça il faut une volonté
politique pour ça il faut des
financements
monsieur comptait 2 quand on vous entend
parler
personne n'est parfait malheureusement
la police nationale non plus j'imaginais
ce que vous entendez quand certaines
personnes dénoncent les violences
policières est ce que selon vous il y en
a mais écoutez moi je suis pas dans le
déni
il ya des racistes dans la police
nationale il ya eu des collègues qui ont
eu des comportements non conformes à la
déontologie
mais ce que je me refuse à dire
contrairement à ce que disent certaines
personnes c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
racisme steet systémique pardon de
racisme d'état dans la police nationale
d'ailleurs si c'était le cas ne vous
n'auriez pas ces centaines de policiers
d'origine africaine ou maghrébine qui
rentre dans la police nationale
aujourd'hui par vocation ainsi la pluie
c'était un corps racistes ces
personnages et rentrerait pas et puis
voilà il ya des enquêtes en cours sur l
igpn
il ya des enquêtes en cours il ya des
collègues et lui ont été déférés devant
les tribunaux qui ont été jugés donc
voila mais ce que je me sens que je me
refuse à faire ce sont des généralités
la police dans ce pays et et la
gendarmerie pardon sont d'essence
républicaine mais il peut y avoir
effectivement ici ou là des
comportements
qui sont qui ne sont pas déontologique
c'est vrai alors on voit bien en ce
moment ça fait même des années que la
situation est tendue entre la police et
une certaine catégorie de personnes
pourquoi selon vous le savez il ya eu un
retard et d'un récent sondage et lab qui
a été diffusée largement qui stipule qui
dit que 70% de la population et sa
police moi je pense qu'il ya une
majorité silencieuse de la population
qui aime sa police simplement qu' elle
ne le dit pas on n'entend plus
fréquemment ceux qui détestent la police
mais vous savez ceux qui détestent la
police le plus ce sont qui ce sont les
voyous
ce sont des personnes qui commettent des
crimes et délits ce qu'il faudrait alors
vous savez idéalement il faudrait
recréer cette vaste police de proximité
qu'avait voulu faire jean-pierre
chevènement à l'époque mais pour ça il
faut des moyens parce que la police de
proximité qui avait été mise en place à
l'époque avait avorté faute de moyens
actuellement nous avons mis en place
c'est gérard collomb qui avait initié la
police de sécurité du quotidien mais
malheureusement il donc beaucoup
d'effectifs pour les mettre en place et
avant de mettre tout ça en place il ya
certains quartiers ou 6 à pacifier vous
avez des policiers qui ne peuvent pas
rentrer dans certains quartiers parce
que sinon ils se prennent immédiatement
des bouteilles des boules de pétanque
sur la figure donc là c'est un réel
problème
on veut bien faire la police de
proximité mais il faut vraiment pas s'y
fier des quartiers alors les quartiers
c'est quoi vous savez dans les banlieues
c'est pareil
vous avez 99 des + 9 % des personnes qui
habitent dans les banlieues qui sont des
gens respectables et qu'ils sont énervés
qui sont vraiment agacé qui n'en peuvent
plus de quelques dizaines de personnes
qui sèment le trouble dans ces quartiers
là monsieur content merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous assure rt france je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental paris unité sgp police
merci